merci monsieur le député Mazar de votre
question qui permet à la fois de faire
un bilan du salon et de donner des
perspectives premier bilan du salon
c'est d'abord la grande affluence qu'il
y a eu qui a permis à de nombreux
Français à nombre d'entre vous et
d'entre nous de voir et de rencontrer
les agriculteurs de rencontrer leurs
difficultés mais de rencontrer aussi ce
que sont leurs attentes et leurs
innovations et leur volonté d'avancer
dans les grandes transitions qui sont à
l'oeuvre vous l'avez dit on a pu au
cours de ce salon évoquer la question de
la souveraineté fruits et légumes avec
l'annonce d'un plan de souveraineté
fruits et légumes on l'a pu aussi
avancer sur les questions de
modernisation de l'appareil dans la
ligne droite de ce qui a été fait dans
le plan France 2030 et France Roland
préalablement pour montrer à quel point
nous voulons accompagner l'agriculture
dans les grandes transformations qui
sont à l'oeuvre vous l'avez dit aussi on
a besoin de donner un cap à
l'agriculture si je devais donner un
seul cap c'est celui de la souveraineté
la souveraineté au fond c'est quoi la
souveraineté s'est donnée les moyens de
production les moyens de production
c'est quoi c'est l'accès aux fonciers
c'est l'accès au capitaux c'est l'accès
à l'eau c'est l'accès aux moyens de
production globalement qui permettront
aux agriculteurs de faire face aux
grands défis qui sont les nôtres le
deuxième élément de la souveraineté
c'est de faire face aux dérèglement
climatique et aux nouveaux besoins en
termes environnemental c'est de donner
les moyens par la recherche par
l'innovation par l'accompagnement à
l'investissement à nos agriculteurs de
pouvoir se transformer d'évoluer le
statut quo en agriculture avec le
dérèglement climatique serait une grande
peur une grande crainte et un grand défi
si nous n'arrivions pas le relever et il
me semble qu'on a besoin de travailler
sur ce sujet là le troisième sujet c'est
le sujet aussi de la rémunération c'est
ce que nous avons commencé à faire dans
regalim on envoie les premiers résultats
ne soyons pas trop péremptoire ou trop
autosatisfait mais on a vu les premiers
résultats des galets on a besoin de
rémunération parce que sans rémunération
il y aura pas d'attractivité des métiers
pas de capacité à investir pour les
agriculteurs voilà les éléments qu'on a
et puis vous avez dit pas d'agriculture
on dit souvent pas d'agriculture pas de
paysans pas de pays sans paysans c'était
la phase de Raymond Lacombe nous avons
besoin nous avons besoin de renouer avec
une ambition agricole parce que la
France est forte quand son agriculture
est forte et c'est bien le cas le cap
que vous nous voulons tracer en termes
de souveraineté